I'm joined today by Donald light who's a
professor at the Rowan University School
of Osteopathic Medicine he specializes
in pharmaceutical pharmaceutical
industry myths which is a topic that is
very very interesting certainly to me
and I know too much of our audience
Donald it's great to talk to you talk to
us big picture when we talk about myths
in the pharmaceutical industry what
types of myths are we talking about oh
well we're talking about the claims by
the industry year in and year out and
that their research costs are
astronomical and they are the principal
reason why prices to patients have to be
so high that they drain the household
you know live income and a lot of you
know poorer families have to choose
between food and their medicine that's
often a come up in discussions about
even with the current administration
about sort of lowering prescription drug
prices and one of the facts that's often
pointed out is that well the prices that
are being charged in the United States
are exponentially higher in many cases
than the prices that are being charged
for the same drug in other countries so
it appears to not logically follow that
those prices are absolutely necessary in
order to recoup research costs right I
mean it seems as though this is a
market-based approach to pricing where
in countries where pharmaceutical
companies can charge more they are
absolutely glad to Wow that's right so
basically every other affluent country
similar to the United States the major
other sources of both research and
development and and purchasing have set
up a systems for evaluating how much
better new drugs are than existing drugs
or worse what they're they're often
safety problems so one out of every four
new drugs leads to serious adverse
effects and most people don't know that
but it's been repeatedly found and and
then they they set the price accordingly
the thing is that the FDA and the
European
and regulators approve a lot of drugs
that are very similar to existing drugs
and then they're marketed as new and so
other countries say well those drugs
aren't much better so we're not going to
pay you much more and and therefore
their prices are a good good deal lower
while here the drug lobbyists are there
more than twice as many lobbyists as
members of Congress and they they work
very closely with congressmen to put
things in for example prohibiting
Medicare from competing for prices for
having competition between manufacturers
for getting on the formulary and all
that leads to prices being about three
times higher than they are in Canada and
major countries in Europe now to play
devil's advocate what about the argument
that okay
different prices are being charged in
different countries but it does connect
the research and development costs
because the overwhelming amount of
research and development costs are being
incurred in the United States
and thus they are totally within their
rights to recoup the majority of those
costs in the United States does that
argument hold any water well it's a it's
a widely promoted view by the industry
and I don't think it does
it it kind of assumes there are national
buckets or silos so if that were really
true then then you'd have to shut down
all the great research going on in
Switzerland because there aren't very
many people in Switzerland and their
prices aren't that high and so then
you'd say well you know we're just gonna
have to shut down our operations in
Switzerland because we're not getting
enough income to recoup our R&D and and
that same kind of arguments being made
here about us prices and us markets
versus us Rd but in fact any good new
drug is marketed throughout the world so
for instance viagra was developed in
England using British pounds
and my point is and anyone who knows the
international markets would say it
doesn't matter you know then Pfizer will
sell viagra throughout the world and so
it's it's based on a false kind of
buckets or silo argument there's another
layer to sort of the mythology around
R&D costs which is that once you
establish what the R&D costs sort of
really are and and as you're pointing
out that that can be sort of difficult
to do there's also the reality that a
lot of those costs are not just outflows
from the private pharmaceutical company
a lot of the the research that these
developments are built on are research
that is publicly funded and that in a
sense taxpayers have sort of already
paid for isn't that right that is
correct
taxpayers pay even more than that a good
deal more than that so they pay for a
lot of the very high risk in basic
research to discover a you know a new
molecule a new way to treat a disease
and that's all borne by the public
including very high rates of failure but
also American taxpayers pay somewhere
between 40 and 60 percent of all the
company R&D in addition because that
huge network of lobbyists more than
twice the size of Congress have over the
years put in place all kinds of
deductions and tax credits and tax
subsidies for supporting R&D and they
make the same kind of argument we need
all the subsidies and tax credits and
deductions that we can get because
research is so very very expensive now
but that means that the public ends up
subsidizing a good proportion of the
company Rd as well what about the
argument that can be made and again I'm
not necessarily making this argument but
it's an argument that's made which is
that listen the development of these
drugs
benefits society at a much wider level
once you account for all of the negative
externalities diseases and conditions so
number one it makes some sense for
taxpayers to be supporting that research
and number two if you didn't dangle the
possibility of massive profits in front
of these companies they would not be
quote incentivized by the market to even
do it and then we would be lacking a lot
of these great medications how does that
sound to you well it's you know if it's
plausible but it's a matter of degree so
first of all we we have a long tradition
in the United States as to other
countries publicly subsidizing research
that benefits all of a nation's people
and even the world in electronics and
and lots of other fields it's a matter
of degree how much of a monopoly price
setting do you allow in return for that
and in the case of pharmaceuticals
we have other related evidence that most
of the research being done by
pharmaceutical companies is not for
important new drugs that are clinically
better for patients but for minor
variations on already existing drugs so
that these new drugs offer few or no
additional benefits for patients and the
FDA doesn't even require evidence that
new drugs are clinically better for
patients to be approved which I find
amazing it seems to me that we should
only approve new drugs that are
clinically shown to be clinically
effective but instead the the
regulations of the FDA which have been
significantly influenced by the industry
allow them to test against indirect
measures of benefits and technical
measures of benefits and and and then
they show that they can do that and then
they get approved but after that
independent physician and pharmacy
groups fine
that few of those drugs are clinically
better so it's also a matter of the
degree to which that research is being
put two things that really benefit
society it's an absolutely important
issue and I'm so glad to have spoken to
you about it we've been speaking with
Donald light who's a professor at Rowan
University School of Osteopathic
Medicine and we're gonna continue
covering this issue thank you so much
for talking to me today you're welcome